you're probably my favorite actor in the
whole world oh well isn't that wholesome
just in case we couldn't love Keanu
Reeves anymore yes the John Wick star
made the day of one of his biggest fans
Keanu encountered a nine-year-old Noah
at a surprise signing for Berserker the
comic book series that Keanu co-created
and it was all caught on camera in a now
viral video on Twitter
what's your name Noah my name is Noah I
know I'm keoni you're probably my
favorite actor in the whole world oh my
gosh Noah thank you
you like that huh yeah this adorable
interaction continued when the actor
asked if Noah was also a fan of his more
age-appropriate Toy Story character Duke
kaboom
[Music]
posing yeah do Queenie hold on one more
oh yeah did you see Duke kaboom in Toy
Story 4. yeah he's my favorite character
Canada's greatest stunt man
well I'm glad you liked it I really
liked playing dude
Canada has ever seen
Mercy